a manhunt is underway near Toronto
Canada this morning for two men who
bombed an Indian restaurant overnight
police released this surveillance image
of the suspects who set off the homemade
bomb at least 15 people were injured in
the blasts in mississagua that's a
suburb of Toronto Adriana Diaz is here
tracking this investigation Adriana and
good morning good morning so far no one
has claimed responsibility for the
attack and there's no known motive at
around 10:30 last night police say two
men walked into the bomb baybel Indian
restaurant and detonated the IEDs or
improvised explosive device before
taking off authorities have blocked off
the scene and the surrounding area as
they search for the suspects and
evidence video from right after the
explosion shows some of the 15 injured
people being loaded onto stretchers and
taken by ambulance to the hospital
three people were upgraded from critical
to stable condition overnight the others
all suffered minor injuries the suspects
both wore dark zip-up jackets and
covered their faces one could be seen
carrying a device police are not
currently calling a terrorism or a hate
crime they're asking for the public for
any help in identifying the two men
responsible Gary yeah Thank You Adriana